[music]
This is our AI.
We develop it at UMA. It control a
standard robot arm to automate the task
of picking and sorting anchors of
various colors.
It's a single nural network.
So here, nothing here is scripted.
No pre-programmed trajectories, no
hardcoded rules that tell it where to go
or what to pick next.
These robots sees the world's raw pixels
and decides what to do next.
Perception to action, end to end. It's a
bit like you and I when we reach out for
a cup without even thinking about it.
Yeah, this kind of behavior, it's always
amazing to watch.
What's special with this AI is that it
can operate for hours robustly with
precision,
adapting to what it sees.
And so
what you see here is the beginning of
something profound.
AI is moving into the physical world,
embodying the next generation of robots.
Robots that are mobile, they can move
around, dextrous, they can manipulate
different type of objects. And they are
smart. They learn and adapt.
And these robots will help us in our
daily lives. They will be in
manufacturing, in agriculture.
They will be even in services and in
your rooms.
In labs, they will turn years of
research in just a few months.
We won't be limited by our capability to
make, but only by our imagination.
We are entering an era of limitless
creativity.
This might feel like a distant future,
but it will happen much quicker than we
expect because soon enough those robots,
they will be absolutely everywhere and
they will be absolutely needed.
And this is because
we are facing three crisis in our
generation hitting us at the same time
and converging on one bottleneck that
these robots will solve.
And so we need to build these robots now
and we need to build them right. And
that's why nine months ago I co-ounded
UMA to build the universal mechanical
assistant.
So let me tell you
about this crisis through a series of
examples that might be a bit confusing
at first sight. So first crisis
demographic.
In this image, you can see a factory in
southern Germany.
Profitable but shutting down.
Not because demand fell, but because
they could not hire the machinists, the
welders, the technicians.
They tried to raise wages. They tried to
pay for relocation, but nothing worked.
And this is a well doumented phenomenon
happening right now across Europe and
accelerating.
Second crisis environmental
the fact that we know how to stop
climate change. The technology exist.
We need to adapt and build the
infrastructure quickly enough. And for
this you need someone that manufacture,
assemble and install the the technology.
And so in this picture, we illustrate
that
families
stopped their plan to install solar
panel on the roof because it just became
too expensive when the labor is missing.
The third crisis, it's about economy.
It's linked to
supply chain organization worldwide. So
I'm sure you remember co
um we discovered that among the most
powerful nations on earth some were
struggling to manufacture their own
masks and we are just talking about a
piece of paper and elastic.
Another example is the US canal
blockage. one ship stuck the all uh the
world economy for two weeks
and and then maybe recently you try to
purchase a new cell phone or a new
smartphone the price uh went up and
that's because of a single choke point
in uh Asia for the manufacturing of RAM.
So
most of the goods that the world
consumed today are manufactured in just
a few places which create massive
dependencies and geopolitical tension
and we are in a in an era where we need
to avoid this at all cost.
So the few examples that I mentioned
they might feel unrelated but they are
not
three crisis
demographic environmental
economic
and they converge on one bottleneck
which is labor its availability and its
cost
and this is accelerating. So if you have
to remember only one statistic it would
be the number of children per family
across every continent
it's going down
and we are almost below the replacement
rate that's the number at which the
global population of the world just
decreased. So this is a a normal
phenomenon just societies evolved.
But for your information,
the US, Europe and China are well well
below this rate already.
As a result, 85 million workers will be
short in less than four years from now.
And this is the equivalent of 8.5
trillion in economic value just gone in
less than four years. And and this can
be compared to the GDP combined the
combined GDP of the UK and Japan.
So three crisis
and one solution.
We need to build this next generation of
robots as quickly as possible. because
they will address the labor shortage and
fill this gap.
So what are the challenges?
First challenge it's building the robot
brain.
This means that we need the ability,
I mean those robots need the ability to
learn as quickly as possible, as
efficiently as possible the task that we
do. And so at UMA, we took a unique
approach.
Even before scaling data and compute,
we came back to the fundamentals
and develop and focused on a radically
efficient learning approach. We call it
realtime learning and it is inspired by
how you and I, we learn.
Do you remember the first time you
learned how to tie your shoes?
I'm sure that u your parents teach it
teach you how to do it like she just
show you the task then you fumbled you
try again you practiced and at some
point your hands just knew and that's
real time learning.
So now please have a look to this video.
So this is our AI controlling two robot
arm
and automating the task of picking and
sorting various items. Actually picking
and scanning and dropping various items.
four items that are extremely
challenging with today technology inter
robotics. So the first item is cables
that are deformable. Then you have
shampoo quite slippery. You have mouse
pad super thin and then you have those
bags that need to be handled with care
because they are fragile.
So you see the the AI retry retry and
then I get it.
Here we are messing with it.
It's amazing to watch. No.
And finally it succeeded.
We really tried hard to mess with it and
still it figures out.
And
this is how you go from one robot doing
one task to billions of robots doing
almost anything.
So now second challenge building the
body of the robot.
Atuma, our conviction is that to learn
like us, to automate the task that we
do, these robots need to be humanoid.
They need a body to navigate our space
and hands to handle our tools.
And so today
I'm extremely excited
to unveil
our northstar design.
We designed it to be approachable,
calm, and competent.
A robot you would feel at ease having
around in your workplace but also at
home. And here you can see it wearing
clothes like futuristic looking kind of
clothes
and
we design it with three safety design
principle.
Safety
is fundamental. It's it is at the core
of what we do at UMA. And it means
caring for people and looking after
them.
And first safety principle, it is
lightweight,
less mass, less kinetic energy. We baked
safety into the physics.
Second, we borrow from iOS space
redundant independence layers of safety
that reinforce each other term of
software systems.
Third, our own world models is dedicated
to safety. before any action.
Our world model predict the outcome
and then it's just enable the movement
only when the path is clear.
And I'm sure that the companies that win
at robotics are not the one that ship
the most units today.
They are the one that earn the trust on
the long term.
And at TUMA we are building the safest
but also the more capable most capable
robot starting with our very first
prototype
develop in our lab to validate the
fundamentals.
We call it version zero.
I like
AI software hardware a small team 9
months
designed and assembled in Paris
and so I often get asked why did you
start UMAR in Europe
it's because it's the best market.
That's where the situation is the most
critical.
Highest demand in term of automation,
highest cost of labor. That's why we
started Umar in Europe and North America
and Asia will soon follow.
In term of go to market,
three steps. First, logistics. That's
where we have control environments.
We can deploy hundreds of robots at a
single site and demand is im immediate.
Second step manufacturing that's where
the requirement in term of dexterity is
higher and third homes where this
technology will increase the
quality of life for everyone.
So now we know what to build, how to
build it, and where to deploy. But how
do we build these robots quickly enough
to address the crisis I talk about?
Let me tell you about smartphones.
From the first iPhone
to as many as people on earth, it took
the industry only 12 years.
But
a smartphone cannot build another
smartphone. A robot can.
So each generation of UMA robots
is going to build the next one
more capable,
safer
and at a speed which is exponential
robots building robots. That's how we go
quickly enough.
So this next generation of robots,
it is about making sure that the work
that holds our society and our life
together still gets done and done for
every one of us.
Every generation faces challenges that
shape the future. And this is our turn.
And at Tuma, we build this future with a
deep sense of responsibility, humanistic
values, and passion.
Thank you.